hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three weird games
now we're starting off with one called
drunk and dad's simulator and I don't
know why you're a bear but I think
everyone can relate to the whole drunk
bear concept I think if I if anybody
wanted to relive the ability of being a
drunk dad
which I guess is something that's pretty
common maybe but if people did then this
would be the proper vehicle to do it a
bear in pajamas who's completely naked
see this this doesn't work if you're
just wearing a shirt it just makes you
look like you're not wearing pants
anyway we got a lot of weird to cover in
a very short amount of time so let's get
into this here we go let's get drunk
buddy hey what's your name pal you know
what Berenstein bears gone bad oh wait
wait hang on ah
number one why I'm the only bear at this
party and I'm - this seems like a kid's
party oh no oh no oh my god I really do
get to hit these these poor unsuspecting
what is this a thing oh god oh god I'm
so sorry okay you may be looking at me
awfully disapprovingly but look listen
there's a wheelchair stop to someone's
face see this oh no buddy Oh buddy are
you okay
I'm sorry here let me help
I think I can help if I just give a give
a sweet swift bap oh wait for it oh yeah
you're all better now I hope you didn't
need that we all know this this oh
[Music]
excuse me I don't know where I okay well
I knocked myself out I'm only a threat
to myself and literally everybody at
this party okay can I have some beer
please no I don't know if I need money
oh my god
why did a nuke go off
where's nobody worried about the nuke
okay alright a little concerned but an
Arg Arg Oh bouncy oh where am i oh hey
how's it going there
don't mind me just gonna grab another
unsuspecting beer and nothing Bad's
gonna happen as a result all right thank
you okay let me try say I / speed
[ __ ]
excuse me bard mace sorry oh yeah
okay here we are okay here we go one
more one more big one there we go
attaboy not a bear
that's a big bear that's a big bear boy
alright what else we got to do well how
am I supposed to get that oh how am I
supposed to be able to see that excuse
me douche douche oh okay
seems very strange that I have tactical
nukes oh and then it's gonna burn the
tree down so I don't think my cousin
smoke you would approve of that too much
but okay I'll take that thank you
bling okay good good good moves all
around cake is that cake yeah awesome
okay can I have some please pretty
please excuse me oh that's that's
probably very scarring for those
children then again looking at the
children they might be already be pretty
scarred as it is I can't get to that
okay excuse me pardon me excuse me
hello buddy oh ah I know how to do this
now oh yeah oh no no there we go there
we go there we go
that's the good [ __ ] okay here we go
can you oh wow oh my spine now all my
torquing muscles are really working
against me now
okay well it's something out of a horror
movie
oh my God look if you want cake that
badly
take a bite out of it Jesus okay well I
guess I've thoroughly inspected this
cake hey aah hey aah hey aah is this not
the correct way to oh I already got it
yeah okay so somehow I'm there we go aah
and we're fine right well we're totally
fine oh oh ow all right well that's an
option
aah how about no is he gonna blow up I'd
be awfully surprised if he blew up do
also what does this kiss bunnies ooh oh
hey someone throw a beer in my mouth -
hey throw a beer hey whoa whoa why is it
bureau wait no found give me that bear
no give me no give me yeah oh I got a
crowd-surf oh I get it
that's funny okaying on oh don't give me
that bear there we go and then I died of
alcohol poisoning
okay so that was drunk dad simulator so
just like all the drunk dads we know
about right great job
welcome to the Confraternity of toast
now that's a weird name of a game and
the promo screenshots for this were even
weirder but everyone was saying that
this game was not what it seemed to be
and you've heard that a lot when it
comes to horror games but this one
people seem to be especially concerned
about what this game held in it so I'm
gonna be going into this with no
knowledge of what it could possibly be I
don't think I have anything extra to do
so ah this is extra oh thank you thank
you for this this is lovely
oh okay oh oh that's how I leave okay
all right well hey that's that's great
so let's get into the actual cam and see
what the hell's going on Oh bye oh
you're you're wait what what I spies Oh
blasphemous we don't have any price we
can't be bought with your money I saw
that toast down there I see you doesn't
mean I want to go there but I see you I
guess okay hey how's it going hi my name
is Mark Blair I can't go that way okay
nevermind then invisible wall see you
around the bend
I guess picnic area is that where Baldy
has his picnic oh oh
help me I don't think I can
this feels like the aftermath of like I
am bread okay alright well I'm gonna
just go in here cuz that's all a
cemetery
well we gotta go to the cemetery see
what's the happy happens over here toast
oh it's a bunch of toast but there's
some over here oh oh you are
ah so scary oh my god I'm so scared
it's my grave okay whatever
fine what didn't it say like y /n oh it
would have been spookier ma not my name
oh my god
Confraternity of toast but the house is
right here but the front door oh it's
clock this button it's it's closed it's
real closed okay let me go see the
Confraternity of toast whatever the hell
that means
looks like I don't know bread coming out
of a grave or something hi Brad
hello oh all right oh hi oh oh this is
that bus why did this bus crash in my
backyard Oh Oh cuz it was oh [ __ ] you're
still alive okay you know I never mind
then oh hi kill all humans okay it's
time to take revenge
hello I love programming oh okay and I
think I could go up the ramp back here
that was created by some chimney falling
over or something like that anyway do
you have anything to say praise the
Confraternity alright yeah the
Confraternity I'm super down for the
Confraternity what are you doing how am
I supposed to be able to get to you jump
[Applause]
okay I jumped here only a jump well
you're not wrong I guess alright so I
guess I'm supposed to hoop okay here we
go
oh so I am poor $1 please I don't even
think I have money horn oh ho King toast
what is happening
JQ Marzian J'Accuse what am i doing
versus yes No oh hi I'm the glorious
founder of this beautiful girl Erna t
kneel in front of me young subject now I
will ask you to answer him imagine you
want to join the kind of fraternity yes
or no um you guys haven't even W our
superior okay--oh nope nope on this one
I'm not going old no purrs like a big
big big knope's have epic knope's
present a tanner oh okay I guess I'm
done now oh hope okay oh my god little
joke I'm funny I'm funny oh you are
funny you're real funny okay all right
super funny good joke good joke oh I
hope you understand the importance of
never contradicting your superior we
will be a big happy family join the
Confraternity um I'm good you know I'm
go ah all right so I don't have a choice
huh
oh I can't even go back up there anymore
wait what happens if I can't go I can't
say no oh just our God has say yes then
whatever alright here we go
Oh welcome
Oh joke use prohibited items torch
alcohol book identity card toaster your
ideas weapons all that is yours oh
that's it huh a message for aspiring
confer roars hello young toast if you
want to enter the glorious Confraternity
of does you have to go to the sacred
temple
you'll receive orders there and remember
have a strong respect for the
authorities okay whatever you say man
I'm happy to be here oh you sure are man
I can tell by the look on your toasty
face one plus one equals zero I'm a
genius okay all right follow the mass
all right
I do like gaining more mass books are
useless TV has all the answers
Oh tears tea transport as a monopoly on
trades Oh what does what does it mean
what does any of this mean Chucky Lou's
toast lease really the toast lease toast
lease keeps the city safe
oh are you following me my house is big
30 square meters Wow okay
Oh illegal ice cream shop okay I'm a
unicorn
you sure are okay all right what are you
doing hiding behind this bush back here
today was a magnificent day oh you were
hiding just to tell me that huh okay all
right thank you no more no more dudes I
think I've talked to you okay those
please okay I'll go now I like plastic
trees okay good for you uh anybody
hiding out in the woods over there oh
hello there was something oh hi small
toes small and beautiful right
you sure are just like me small and
beautiful oh hi
okay all right I'm gonna go through
whatever the hell this is oh all right
okay maintenance
[Laughter]
mine is gonna mail help me use me I
don't know
hello young toes go join the girls you
have to three tests and the first test
you will level to overcome a difficult a
sin the second test your parkour skills
will be put to the test and the last
test you will have 200k test 1 the
labyrinth
Juke use ok I just gotta go through a
maze so I'll be back once I get through
this maze huh oh I made it what those by
pure luck
what the hell did I oh I did oh thank
goodness
good bad all right Park Cortez Juke use
ok here we go
whoa oh whoa I don't like the little -
little - whoa okay why you slowed no I'm
not gonna like this am I oh no I'm not
gonna like it at all get ready for a
repeat ah
so I'm gonna put a fail counter up okay
here we go
Oh dah I keep thinking I'm gonna
overshoot it I don't mother humper oh
god okay yes please thank you for all of
this Oh big baby oh my god I think
running is gonna be the death of me so
I'm not gonna oh nevermind running is
gonna be the savior of me and I'm only
gonna run hole
left or right that's not what you said
on the sign but you know it's it's what
I read in my head oh that's what you
meant
that's what you meant oh okay I get it
dog [ __ ] I'm a big old bag of poop
and I have no idea where this game is
taking me or why or how I didn't even
want to be part of your stupid
fraternity of toast
okay it was no it's the one that the
signs on oh of course it is
oh it's the one that the sign is uh-oh
you know what I'm just gonna look mostly
down when I do this because I think
that's the only thing that's gonna help
me oh [ __ ] there's just some wonky
physics on the platforming it's like
sometimes it goes forward after you stop
and sometimes it do not Chuck Hughes Oh
Joe Hughes okay jock use Joe Hughes okay
ha ha it's too slanty it's two slots
just lantee oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god just give me there just
give me there
okay give me there come here come here
I'm going I'm speedrunning this [ __ ] oh
my god sobbing I got it I got it
speed run you just gotta go fast you
gotta be confident I'm so unbelievably
confident Oh Frick me Joe oh my god fast
is not gonna be able to do it but here I
go I can't now go fast now okay here we
go I'm fast I'm fast and speedy speedy
like Bonnie do you like Bonnie oh boy
okay that's fine I'm gonna take my time
with it oh come on oh why why why why
why why why why what oh come on
okay well if I just miss entirely it's
no point
right into it right into the red well
that's the first time I died - the red I
should mark a special symbolic and
gesture
oh come on
well then alright Oh God I have to go
more up when I hit that or else I will
slide off which is very stupid oh come
on
oh why god dammit why yeah I have to the
thing is like I have to tap backwards
just before I land right into it just
before I land or else I will slide
forward after see there's that slide I'm
just exploiting now I'm to the point
where I'm explaining why I'm failing and
you know and that does nobody anybody
cuz you don't care right but it's hard
it's hard what I'm saying is that it's
hard it's hard it is hard you play it
you play it dammit you're playing it's
does not me being dumb the games is hard
it's hard to get it precise it's hard
you have to like you have to stop your
momentum or else you'll just slide
forward you know what I mean you don't
know what I mean because you're not
playing it go oh okay here we go alright
how I don't know how they expect me to
do this
I lost it because it's hard it's hard to
stay in one spot it is it's super hard
just to land where I want to and it's
really hard guys it's real hard then we
go uppy uppy uppy and we don't eat we
did it who did it jump there I don't
trust any of this [ __ ] okay
why no no that's a lie that's a lie I
think that's a lie if I go down this and
it sets me back to the beginning that's
a lie it's a lie it's a lie it's a love
guard [ __ ]
[Music]
woah that was the maze holy [ __ ] I made
it through that oh my god escape okay oh
I didn't like that oh oh train equals
death ray whoa alright well I got uh
yeah I'm just not gonna walk on the I'm
gonna walk on that what is that that's
not good is it
you Shh well that's probably not good
corrosive oh no joke huh oh no kidding
no kidding no way it's corrosive you
think alright okay alright well this
ain't so bad I hope no train decides to
roll
whoosh okay I don't know where I'm going
now the Confraternity of toast is just
goddamn bizarre alright
we're yeah okay oh oh oh hey oh hi hello
I just fell off you're scared I'm scared
too I don't know what's happening oh boy
where am I what's with all the boxes ooh
okay boo boo Boop where are you taking
me where am I going
where is it's taking me oh here
we're here now what the hell is
happening I'm so confused
I just have so many questions so many
non ideas of what's going on so many
just absolute balls-to-the-wall insanity
okay so what was this door it's closed
you know [ __ ] that's how doors work you
close them and then you open them there
you want to go that so that's how doors
work man I'm putting my parkour skills
to the test
Wow Oh Oh J'Accuse
oh [ __ ] traffic all right oh that's why
the doors were there oh okay
oh so weird oh where am I going why do I
need to escape this never would have
happened
oh is that trash compactor where's that
train train so I need to escape in the
Train huh whoa I see I see I see oh I
see lag boy oh oh hey okay you don't see
me I'm I'm not here
whoa there's no lag looking this way
there's incredible lag looking this way
okay okay all right why are we here
Joe coos thank you for this transport
All Right see ya what is this
what kind of mythological monstrosity
are they trying to make for this toast
who they doing
Oh toast machine server status online
override suicide is at an all-time high
riots are at a medium you are here dude
don't press the button oh [ __ ]
Oh oh wait no I regret I take it back no
no no all right well then I'm in the
jacuzzi name hello
I toast do you have any oh okay nope I
don't like oh I don't like that no I
don't like that okay hi
hello you will die if you go ahead Oh
ass ass cut it it it right oh I missed
that other one on whatever budget tell
me I'm gonna die again okay thank you
thank you for that I don't know I'm
jumping ever since that parkour section
I just can't stop jumping I mean it's
kind of cool I guess got some cool glow
on those bad boys after that one not so
glowy but okay big arrow
I trust the arrow Oh
third test ride a unicorn and live happy
you mean that guy with the ice cream on
his head that unicorn Oh
the arrows seem to be pointing inwards
Oh what the hell
whoa I don't like this at all I don't
like this at all there's absolutely
nothing to like about any of this it's
just pitch blackness with the howling
song of the Damned in the distance what
I don't want to ride a unicorn I don't
want to ride a unicorn I don't want a
unicorn to ride me I don't want any of
that okay I guess there was nothing out
there I'll go up the ramp yeah sure okay
oh good more ramp hi I thought that was
a face I'm so confused
oh my grave my grave okay the
Confraternity of toast turns out we're
all
turns out we're all dead we're all dead
whoo you you you need a lot of graves
you so big huh thank you thank you okay
I hate it I hate it I hate it free money
whoo free money you see all right well
don't mind if I don't this seems like a
trap but hey free money everyone's
laughing at how smart I am and how
clever I is yeah okay free money all
right I maybe I shouldn't have taken the
free money maybe I shouldn't have done
that okay all right
hey whoa you're drinking at my grave oh
thank you for that thank you
how you doing buddy you're good you
having a good old party okay good for
you okay I'm just gonna keep going
okay all right thank you for that oh hey
how you doing there buddy Wow whoa look
at you you really moved up in the world
or down depending on your perspective
okay all right cool thank you for that
Oh tippy tappy another parkour test I
can pass you I'm so good at this
press EDA tyo yo you for youth all right
I'll do that buddy hey how you doing out
here you doing good you're doing good
how are you doing the dreams don't exist
wake up
you mean dreams of toast don't tell me
that they don't exist I don't know what
I'd do if my toasty dreams didn't exist
but I got free money so that's pretty
cool you know pretty cool oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh you P you big
good thing I did all those parkour
things cuz I'll never be able to get
through that my bus
no sale sign no nothing what I'm curious
about right now is like are there
multiple endings to this game you think
you're there you know there are multiple
endings do you have some glue oh no no
do not know I'm sorry I do not have glue
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh no you [ __ ] bag no oh well
that's fine okay why are we here there's
a crown can I take that cool crown I
guess oh there's no house here oh
alright
I'll do I'm just gonna go to bed I have
a funny feeling like this is all just a
wacky dream Bing bong
oh another strange dream
yeah and back in my again another
stressful workday it's time to finish it
what am i what am i finishing oh that's
my name number three four seven six one
five five three that's that's me
that's what my mama named me oh it
reminds me I suddenly got a reminder
that game I played a long long time ago
where there was this worm that was just
dripping blood from the sky oh ah okay
yeah that that makes sense
Chuck Hughes dude I don't even
understand anything I don't understand
the damn thing that happened there okay
I guess that's it and I I guess I guess
that's it I miss the extra screen I like
the extra III like the extra I was good
that's good stuff extra extra read all
about it okay
so that was the Confraternity of toast
yeah it wasn't what it seemed it was
just flipping weird from start so yeah
welcome to Dante's Inferno this is game
about a cat now I'm not sure if you play
the guy with the beard of the guy with
the cat or the cat with the guy the guy
with the cat the cat with a guy I'm not
sure which one you play but we're gonna
find out now so let's get into it
root tutorial I'll probably need that
because I have no idea what I'm the
kitty oh I already know I'm gonna love
this game so adorable oh my God look at
me boy oh that's super cute oh that's
that's ridiculously cute head buddy
his nog this bad boy off no oh whoa
there was a game wait there was a game a
while ago that was like a beta game it
was about a cat and you would just have
to knock stuff off of shelves this is
like that but in a whole new dimension
can i double jump ooh wait power jump
Oh scooch my butt I'm above the wiggle
in the kitty cat oh my god oh I love it
bop bop get the bat Thank You whiff I
missed something I packed everything I
thought I could bap
oh there we go got it okay I win all
right
oh my god and through the mystical door
of which we all know that cats Traverse
different universes in okay we got it
okay man Manu let's do this bearded man
you gotta go down huh you think you can
mess with me Huang cos Wow yeah yeah I
bet you regret not feeding it whoa that
was a cool wall jump maneuver oh oh he's
mad oh he's very mad you hipster [ __ ] ha
you think you can mess with me huh just
cuz you feed me does not mean you own me
oh [ __ ] gay man ah oh hey no not today
and a Boeing and nibbling a Boeing oh
boy
no oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] huh okay Dave
Heights get rekt you hipster douche oh
no you I'm gonna get your final
collection next oh I like the climbing
that's nice but it's not so nice he
doesn't know where I am stupid idiot in
too many triple espressos you can't even
see where I am alright there we go
that's good
okay oh no I'm so sorry not love that
he's on fire mad hey sorry Bubba look
listen if you weren't just a giant piece
of garbage I guess I would
Oh what is he doing oh is that the
picture of your wife or something
okay maybe I'm maybe I might be a little
sorry about that but not about these
some days he's resetting one of them no
no no oh no wait I see no no no kitty no
no no all right I'm Audi I'm Audi baby
see yeah
this is coming to your house and just
wreck all your [ __ ] that you could
absolutely nothing that's it there's a
bad exchange all right little two then
all right nut nut nice
oh he is oh he is furious as he should
be
was that a picture of him and me well
that's what a loyal cat daddy I'm just a
giant piece of [ __ ] well if he just
wasn't such a hipster about it I
probably would be a little less douchey
a point ah
no not today don't put me in the bath oh
no no no no here we go yeah what you got
what you got man no not today
oh-ho-ho listen oh he doesn't know what
to do he's so lost and confused
unfortunately for him I am NOT I'm so
goddamn cute I'm so goddamn cute and
he's so mad
ah no please not today Oh mr. man do you
not know where I am
mr. man I think he's sad oh [ __ ] you
know I think he knows you might know you
might know something about this oh well
someone's a steamy pile of poopy humma
dope bobaloo banana go bye-bye
oh boo gotta gotta gotta got it ha ha ha
ha miss me ah [ __ ] gotta get up there oh
ha ha ha ha right on your noggin you
stupid idiot oh oh hey you almost got me
there that would have been impressive
but sadly for you you're just too stupid
to be able to be me alright let's see if
I can get some distance on him huh does
this do oh I don't know what that did
but it made it a lot moodier in here oh
oh oh I thought shot the music off I was
like oh that's not is nice less and less
and less and less and less and I don't
know what that other cat was but it's
out of here
how do you have so many alarm clocks
it's cuz you're a hipster god damnit of
course you do actually have Bell alarm
clocks
you goddamn weirdo I'm going down oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] we've gotten into
baldies territory he's glitching up on
me oh come on get it get it yeah yes
good stuff yeah it's what I would
colloquially refer to as the good stuff
yeah oh there's another room Oh where's
the other room wait there's more stuff
here
oh it's / floors oh okay uh-huh haha
scary scary scary okay it's scary very
scary oh wait I just spotted the mother
lode
oh yes please Oh
power jump No Oh power jump I'm a kiddy
on a mission and that mission is to
literally destroy your life oh ho these
are hard to navigate okay that's that's
difficult pe come on oh come on oh come
on yeah yeah totally worth it 100% worth
it hey how did I miss this get out here
okay woo hey you almost got me there
but not today not today buddy boo oh I'm
surprised stash I'm like a missile of
pure hate here to wreck your [ __ ]
hate hate this hate that ooh TV oh
that's nice
and I don't think about picking anything
I'm gonna scratch your eyes out now oh
yeah oh yeah oh no what were you gonna
do you can't do nothing I'm on your face
or are all right what happens when he
gets me what happens when it gets me
come on what you gonna do huh you got
nothing you got nothing buddy because so
sad when he doesn't NAB me I'm on your
shoulder what are you gonna do about
nothing
ow God what is he doing to me was he
even doing he put me in oh no not the
crane oh god no oh I've been a bad kitty
this gives fun trophy room what did I
get
ooh well he really wouldn't want me
mashing up stuff here woody hey listen
can I just can I just be nice
just sit on your lap and just give a
good old / how about right on the tippy
top of your noggin that's though whoa
come on
oh you're stupid hipster topknot is
getting in the way all right this is
good enough hey buddy how are you doing
listen we can be pals right we can be
pals data very be fair they fed me
you're gonna regret that he doesn't seem
mad what all these trophies for Best
organic guava okay I think we got it
ready F Bay bye bye master alright so
anyway that was ridiculous so that was
Dante's Inferno I like that that was a
lot that was a lot of fun I can't
remember the name of the game of the the
one where you played as a cat what was
the name of that one it was it was
really cool anyway so that's gonna
finish off three weird games thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoyed this one these were some weird
ones but there were some fun ones too so
thanks again and if you got any other
weird games that you want me to play or
surreal or just plain old bizarre let me
know down in the comments below thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]